Let's pray together over day 18, Holiness Means Loving God
With All Your Heart.
Lord, we thank you for the clear teaching of the
master teacher, Jesus.
Thank you that He points us to the most important, the first
things,
to love God with all of our heart
and all of our soul and all of our mind.
Lord, we pray that you would enable us to do this.
Thank you for giving us this command.
Thank you for calling us to it with such a clear call.
Lord, it's hard to believe that you would bring this
about in the life, in the heart of such
broken people, such sinful people as we are and
have been.
And yet, Lord, here we are because we believe
that all of the Trinity, the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit,
has willed our holiness, and that you have
chosen it as the pathway before us.
And so, Lord, we don't know what else to do except to rest upon your
promise and to have enough faith that what you have asked of
us, you will also perform within us.
So, Lord,
clean out our hearts.
Do whatever it takes to take away from us the love of the
praise of men and the love of self and the
love of gifts instead of the giver and love of created
things instead of love of the Creator.
Lord, would you help our hearts to be drawn to love
you perfectly so that we may love our neighbor perfectly as
well? Lord, bring it to completion.
Bring it to fullness in our hearts so that we don't draw
back and we don't always be making excuses for why we
are not what you have called us to be.
Instead, Lord, bring us to that place of fullness, we pray.
In Jesus' good and mighty name.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together in prayer.